PROFESSOR: OK.
Let me also remind you that we
slightly changed the schedule
for next week.
On one of the older schedules,
Tuesday appears as a lab date,
but it's actually Thursday.
So Tuesday will be a
regular lecture here
and Thursday will be the lab.
And for the lab,
we meet in 1115.
That's on the handout
for the first day.
Also, if you're not
registered for class,
you don't have automatic
access to Stellar, the website.
So we can manually add you,
but you'll have to let us know.
Just send an email to Professor
[? Marzari ?] and myself.
And even better is if you
send an email to both of us.
And then we'll
manually add that.
And we'll put links there to
things like articles and things
that may have restricted access,
copies of the lecture notes,
things like that
will appear there.
OK.
So what I want to go do is go
back to their potential models.
And what we're
going to do today,
is talk a little more
in detail about the sort
of formal or conceptual failures
of pair potential models,
and then how to get addressed
with other empirical models.
But before I do
that, I wanted to--
let's see if I can get this
into place, guess not--
go through a few
practical issues,
since the first lab
is actually on using
pair potentials to model things
so you get a bit of an idea.
So in a potential model, your
energy is written pairwise.
And so essentially
what you need to do
between every pair of atoms--
every couple iJ--
essentially to evaluate
the distance between
them and then put
that in some kind
of energy function.
So this is clearly an
N squared operation
where N is the number
of atoms, since you
have to look for the
distance between every atom
and every other atom.
So if systems get
extremely big--
and that's often
the reason why you
want to use the pair
potentials rather than, say,
a quantum mechanical method--
N squared will get very large.
And people do kind of tricks.
If you have millions
and millions of atoms
in your simulation, if you know
ahead of time that some of them
are very far from the atom on
which J you want to calculate--
energies or forces--
then you really never want
to look further distance.
So people do things like
keeping neighbor lists.
So literally, for every
atom you would know,
well, these other
items or possibly
in its neighbor environment.
So then you really
only have to look
for distances with those atoms.
So if you have a
solid, that's great.
Because if you have a solid,
then the topological relation
between atoms will not change
much during the simulation.
Of course, if you're simulating
a gas or a liquid, they will.
And then what you have to do is
essentially update the neighbor
lists regularly.
And so there's overhead
associated with that.
But the benefit you get
is that you essentially
have an order N system rather
than an N squared system.
I'll show you in a second
some large scale simulations.
Very often, you will
want to relax a system--
so get it to its lowest energy.
And very often, that's done by
calculating the forces on atoms
and literally stepping
down the force.
If you want to do dynamics,
Professor [? Marzari ?]
will later teach you
molecular dynamics.
You also need the
force because the force
will tell you how much atoms
accelerate or decelerate.
You will need to
calculate the force, which
is a potential derivative.
So you're essentially
calculating
the derivative of the
total energy with respect
to a given position.
Same deal.
That's an N squared operation.
You have to sum
over pairs of atoms.
We have to sum over 1 all atoms
for the force on a given atom.
But since they're N atoms,
it's an N squared operation.
In a lot of codes,
the minimization
is done by very standard
schemes-- things
like conjugate gradient,
Newton-Raphson, sometimes often
trivial line minimizations where
you literally just calculate
the force and assume
some kind of elasticity
along the force path.
And so if you know
the force, you
assume you know what
the curvature is
of the energy in that direction.
You kind of can make an
approximation to its minimum
when you do that iteratively.
So you can do that with
very large simulations.
And I wanted to show you sort
of one of the leading edge ones.
I got to get out of
PowerPoint for that
if I can make that work.
OK, here we go.
So what I'm going to show
you is a order million atom
simulation.
This is essentially a cube of
1,000 by 1,000 by 1,000 atoms.
That would make
more than a million.
I forgot to write
down what it was.
Yeah, I wrote down 1,000
by 1,000 by 1,000 atoms.
That would be a billion atoms.
And essentially
what's being done--
and what you see is a
notch on top and on bottom
because there's so many atoms
you don't see the discrete
resolution anymore [? of ?]
[? the ?] [? atoms, ?] [? so ?]
this thing starts to
look like a continuum.
And it's being
pulled from the side.
So you'll see the cracked
grow and dislocation spread.
This is a simulation from Farid
Abraham when he was at IBM.
And of course, if you
have big computers,
you can do big simulations.
So let me show it to you.
So what they
actually did was they
showed just the
dislocations by counting
under-coordinated or
over-coordinated atoms.
So what you're actually seeing
is the dislocation lines.
I mean, if we plotted
all the atoms,
you wouldn't see anything.
You'd just kind of
see green everywhere.
And that's sort of zoom up.
So this is a molecular
dynamic simulation.
And you learn later more about
that, where you essentially
just do Newtonian
mechanics on atoms.
So this is one of these
very large scale things
that you can actually
do with potentials.
Now, you could ask yourself,
what did I learn from this?
This is the kind of work
that my personal opinion
is scientifically not
necessarily all that relevant.
But it's pioneering
work, you know.
This is like Lewis and
Clark who went to the West.
You could always say, what
did we learn from them?
Maybe not a lot, except that
you could get the Pacific.
But it's kind of
pioneering work.
And when people do these
kind of simulations,
it's not as much for the
science as it is probably
for pushing the
envelope and seeing
what can you do with enormous
computational resources.
You really have to fine
tune your algorithms,
your parallelization scheme.
So it's kind of like
flying to the moon which
may have not brought us much.
But there was a lot of
technology fine tuned for that.
So that's one of the
reasons I wanted to show it.
OK, let's go back.
Another very practical issue
that I'm sure a lot of you
are familiar with.
Even when you have
a billion atoms,
it's actually still very small.
I actually think if you do the
calculation, a million atoms
is, for a lot of materials,
a cube of just about 200
Angstrom on the side
so you're still,
if these were finite systems,
would be very small systems.
So to get rid of
boundary effects,
you almost always use what's
called periodic boundary
conditions in simulations in
as many directions as you can.
And of course, what a
periodic boundary condition
means is that if you have some
unit, if you have some unit,
you essentially
repeat it next to it.
So this end here is
the same as that end,
and this end here is
the same as that end.
So people always
ask you how many
atoms do you have
in your simulation,
and the answer is infinite.
It's just that you only have
a finite number of degrees
of freedom because it's
these atoms here do
exactly the same as these here.
But the answer is infinite.
So we don't really work
with small systems.
Or, rarely.
I mean, sometimes we
work with finite systems.
So what's the
repeat unit you use?
Well, if you're studying
a periodic material,
then it's easy.
If you study, say, a perfect
crystalline material,
here's a perovskite unit,
so that's what you repeat.
Because the material already
has periodicity implied in it.
So at that point,
you're actually
not making any approximation.
You're not forcing
anything on the material--
not when you do a static
calculation that it already
doesn't have.
Of course, when you
do dynamics, you're
enforcing something
because you're
saying that in dynamics, the
translational symmetry is
temporarily broken because this
atom can vibrate independent
of that one.
And so, then, when you
improve impulse periodicity,
you are imposing that
these vibrate together.
So in some sense,
you're imposing a cutoff
on the frequencies of
vibrations that can occur.
If systems don't
have periodicity,
you typically tend
to enforce it.
If I took this perovskite
and I made one defect--
say I wanted to study
oxygen vacancy so I take out
the oxygen vacancy, I lose all
translational periodicity now.
But what you do is you
tend to impose it back
by repeating the defect.
It's going to be slow.
So let's say I've taken
out an oxygen here.
I repeat the defect
so that, in essence,
I just have a bigger unit cell.
But it's one with
a defect in it.
This is now my unit cell.
And that's called a
supercell approximation.
So you make a cell that's
big enough so that you
hope that these defects--
I don't know how you call it--
don't interact because
then, if you have N cells,
your calculation just has
the energy of N defects.
OK?
And the critical
assumption is, of course,
that they don't interact.
Because if they
interact, then you're
not modeling an isolated defect.
You're modeling a defect that's
interacting with other ones.
So how do they
interact typically?
It's kind of important to know.
This is one of these things that
you're going to do in the lab.
You should always check
conversions if you can.
The problem is that
often you already work
at your computational limits
for size of supercells,
so it's easier said than done.
In an ideal world,
you say, well, I
calculate bigger and bigger, and
if the answer doesn't change,
I take it.
But usually, you work so much
at your computational edge
already that you can't make
them bigger and bigger.
A lot of people forget
that [? to ?] [? check ?]
[? conversions, ?] you
also can make it smaller.
And if it doesn't
change much, you
were probably already converged.
But it's useful to know
how these things usually
interact with each other.
So that gives you some sense
of how far you have to go.
There's often the direct
sort of interaction.
If you work with
a pair potential,
then you can actually see the
range of the pair potential.
That's usually not the problem.
Rarely do you have potentials
that are relevant, large,
and over large distances
that you need to make
really large supercells.
But there can be other
energetic effects.
If you have electrostatics
in your system,
that will give you very
long range interaction.
If that's a charge defect--
which it is in a perovskite--
you will have a very strong one.
Actually, if we truly
did a charge defect
in that supercell,
what would happen?
If that supercell
became charged--
so let's say I
took out an oxygen
2 minus, which means
the supercell now
has a net positive charge--
what would happen?
You'd have an infinite energy
because you would essentially
have a positive charge
interacting with only other net
positive charges.
And at any distance, if
you do an infinite system,
that gives you an
infinite energy.
So that's something
that you would
have to explicitly take out.
Now you say, well,
I'll compensate
with a negative charge because
that's what happens in reality.
If I take out an oxygen,
those two electrons
of that or O2 minus are
going to go somewhere,
so it's going to create
a net positive charge.
So then you have a dipole.
So let's say I have
sort of plus, minus,
and I have a dipole now.
So now I have
dipoles interacting.
Dipoles will not give
you infinite energy,
but they will give you a
fairly long range energy tail.
And if you're smart about it--
so the brute force way to
convert supercell calculation
is always to push him as
hard as you can and hope
and sort of see the energy
converge of the defect.
But if you're
smart about it, you
can often do much
smaller cell calculations
and explicitly take
out the term that's
the defect-defect interaction.
Which is, if you know
that this is a dipole,
you know what the form is of
it, and you can take it out.
Other things that often
cause havoc is relaxation.
If I were to put
a really big ion
in the center of that
perovskite unit cell,
I would build up a strain
field and the different defects
would interact through
their strain field.
So, rarely do you
actually interact
through the direct energetics.
You often interact
through secondary effects.
Another way they often interact
which is very indirect.
If you put in your
defect and you
relax the volume
of the supercell,
then that will interfere
with the relaxation
of the supercell next to it.
So you get a strain field
just through the homogeneous.
You get an extra
energy term just
through the homogeneous
strain interaction.
So these are all
things to consider when
you do supercell calculations.
We're trying something new
where we save the annotations
we make on the slides, but
it seems to be really slow.
So I may not be able
to keep that up.
OK, so this I went over--
the kind of convergence.
You know, here's
a typical example.
I don't know if this is typical.
This is the vacancy
formation energy in aluminum.
Now, this is done with
quantum mechanics,
versus the number of
atoms in the supercell.
And you know, this
is one of these
that you really don't
know if you're converged.
I mean, it depends on
how accurate you want it.
If you really only care that
it's between 0.7 and 0.75,
you're probably OK.
But if you did this
point and that point,
you'd probably think
you're converged.
But then, if you
look at the next one,
you're actually going back
up a little bit again.
So it's sometimes very hard
to figure out whether you're
actually converged.
OK.
So that was a few practical
issues to sort of start
gearing you up for the lab.
What I want to do now
is talk explicitly
about some of the formal
failures of pair potentials
and go on to correct them.
And the first one is the
vacancy formation energy
which is, if you look at
historically when people
started doing simulations late
1950s, 1960s, into the '70s,
people thought that
whenever there was something
wrong with the outcome that
they just needed better
parameters in the potential.
And it's actually rather
recent-- sort of 1980s--
that people figured out that
there were really formal
problems and that there were
certain things you could not
get right-- never--
with a potential because
the problem of the form
rather than of the parameters.
And a critical
number in that work
was actually the vacancy
formation energy which
nobody could ever get right.
And I'll show in a second why.
Here's an FCC crystal.
So let's calculate the pair
approximation to the vacancy
formation energy.
What do I do when
I make a vacancy?
What I do is that I
take this central atom
and I move it somewhere
else in the bulk.
So in some sense, I make
my system one side bigger.
So let's calculate the
energy balance of that.
So the vacancy formation energy.
OK.
What do I destroy?
I destroy 12 bonds because this
atom is coordinated 12-fold
in FCC.
So I destroy 12 bonds.
I lose 12 times the bond energy.
But then, of course, I put it
back somewhere in the bulk.
And so I gained the
cohesive energy of one atom.
OK?
And what's the cohesive
energy per atom in FCC?
It's 6 times the bond
energy because there
are 12 bonds around an
atom, but every bond
is shared between two.
OK?
So there's six per atom.
So the vacancy formation
is really minus 12 times
the bond energy plus 6
times the bond energy.
So what it is is minus 6
times the bond the energy.
So essentially, it's
minus the cohesive energy.
The cohesive energy per atom.
And that's essentially
what you will always
find repair potentials.
Now, I did a static
approximation.
I assumed that
all of these bonds
were kind of unchanged
as I took the atom out.
In reality, if I take
that central atom out,
the atoms around it
will relax somewhat
and change their bond energy.
But you'll see this when
you do this in the lab.
That will make it from one
time the cohesive energy
to something like 0.9 or 0.95
times the cohesive energy.
Essentially, you find
in pair potentials
that the vacancy
formation energy
is about the cohesive energy.
If you look, on the other
hand, at experimental results
for the cohesive energy--
[INAUDIBLE]---- here's
some experimental data.
So this is for FCC metals,
and this is for Leonard-Jones,
and for noble gases.
The ratio of the
vacancy formation energy
to the cohesive energy.
And what you see is that,
in the noble gases--
which you think of as
well-described by pair
potentials--
you're reasonably close.
Because remember,
noble gases are just
inert shells interacting through
Van der Waals interaction,
and that's how we came up with
the Leonard-Jones potential.
But if you look at the metals,
the vacancy formation energy
is actually only
a small fraction
of the cohesive energy.
And we can never get that
low with pair potentials.
Never.
OK?
Unless you maybe really
have the most odd form
of a pair potential.
But the reason is because there
are certain physics missing
from pair potentials.
So actually, let me go back
for a second to the pair
potentials.
What's the physics here of why
the vacancy formation energy is
so low in real materials?
Remember what I said
before, that bonding
in metals, the bonding
energy goes not linear
in the coordination number.
It's more something like
a rough approximation
would be the square root
of the coordination number.
But essentially, when
you go from 1 to 2 bonds,
your energy goes down
a lot more than when
you go from 11 to 12 bonds.
So why is the vacancy
formation energy so low?
Well, if you think about
what you do when you take out
an atom, you make a lot
of the atoms around it
go from 12 coordination to 11.
So they lose a lot less than
1/12 of the cohesive energy
because the cohesive
energy you could think
of as the average of all bonds.
But around the vacancy, you are
just reducing the coordination
from 12 to 11.
You can actually
make a simple model
if you said that the
cohesive energy was
some constant times the square
root of the coordination.
So rather than linear in
the coordination, which
is what we would get in pair
of potentials, if you calculate
the vacancy formation
energy in this model--
let's do it for FCC.
In FCC, Z is 12.
The vacancy formation
energy, what would it be?
Well, if we put the
atom somewhere back in,
we would gain Z times
the square root of 12.
And then, as we take it
out, what do we lose?
For 12 atoms, we go from
coordination 12 to 11.
So this is the atom in the bulk.
This is actually the change
around where we made the hole.
And if you actually
calculate that--
the vacancy formation energy
over the cohesive energy--
you find that that's 1 plus
12 times square root of 11
over square root of 12 minus 1.
And it's about 0.49.
So in a square
root model, you're
already much closer
to the experiment
where the vacancy
formation energy
is a much smaller fraction
of the cohesive energy.
Another critical
piece of information
was surface relaxation,
which people
had been seeing with
[? LEEDs. ?] If you look
at a metal, typically
if you create a surface,
the difference between the
first and the second layer
becomes smaller.
So in a metal, the first
layer tends to relax inward.
And can somebody explain
to me why that happens?
And typically, you
don't see this.
In pair potentials,
you very often
have about the same distance.
So the first to second
neighbor distance
is often bulk-like and in some
cases actually relaxes outwards
because of competing forces.
But in almost all real systems,
it tends to relax inward.
Why do you think that is?
Yes, [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: True.
But I'm not sure
that that necessarily
makes it relax inward.
The reason it relaxes
inward is because the bonds
between the first and the
second layer strengthen.
That's really what
is a sign of them.
And why do they strengthen?
Because the surface
is under-coordinated.
Remember, if you go
to lower coordination,
you're effectively--
although you're losing
energy and that's
why there's surface energy--
but the energy per bond is
actually becoming stronger.
Remember that I showed you
the potentials for copper?
Remember that for the
copper II molecule--
so where you just had one bond--
had the strongest potential.
The equation of
state gave you where
your were 12-fold coordinate
gave you much weaker potential.
So you see that in
surfaces as well.
If you cut away the bonds here,
the remaining ones strengthen
and they pull the layer in.
The other problem that's
common in pair potential
which I won't say
much about is what's
called the Cauchy problem.
If you write down the
relation between the stress
and the strain
tensor and so this
is the matrix of
elastic constant that
for pair potential C12 and
C44 are always the same.
And this has something to
do with there actually being
a zero-energy strain mold.
Remember that I showed you this?
It's related to the same
issue that in a cubic
or in a square model, you
can actually kind of slide it
without any energy change.
And that actually
puts a constraint
on the elastic constant,
which essentially
translates to C12 being C44.
And the last one--
if you're a practicing
material scientist--
may be one of the
important ones.
But you can essentially not
predict crystal structure
in anything that's covalent.
And metals are covalent.
I know they teach you there's
metallic, covalent, then
ionic bonding.
But metallic is just
delocalized covalent.
And the reason is--
I think you can already
see-- first of all,
potentials tend to go
to close packing always
because they just they want to
have as many atoms around them
as possible because
that's how you
bring the cohesive energy down.
And they don't count that
cost, that if you bring more
around you, your bound
strength weakens.
And they have no
directional dependence,
so they miss those two
important components
to get crystal structure right.
You can actually do
some theory about this,
which was done
already in the '70s
that you actually
need what's called
at least the fourth moment
of the density of states
to get crystal structure right.
And that turns out to be at
least a four-body effect.
So if you actually thought of
potentials as an expansion--
so I'm going to write the energy
as a constant plus an expansion
in two-body terms, three-body
terms, four-body terms, et
cetera, which we don't
even know would converge--
you would have to go at
least up to the fourth order
to get crystal structure
differences right.
OK, so how do you
fix the problem?
There are essentially,
if you look
at the literature of empirical
models, two avenues to go.
You can either make what's
called cluster potentials.
And so, if you don't like
a two-body potential,
you can make a
three-body potential.
And the advantage
of that, once you
have a three-body potential,
you can see angular dependence.
Because if I have three
atoms and they don't interact
just pairwise, but there's
a [? two ?] three-body,
I can include this
bonding angle.
A bonding angle is truly
a three-body concept.
So you can start building
an angular dependence.
The other direction to go
is go to pair functionals.
So you still want to write
the [? energies ?] pairwise--
some pairwise summation.
You just don't want the
cohesive energy per atom
to go linear with
what you sum pairwise
or what you sum as its
environment pairwise.
So we're going to deal
with both in class.
Today, I'm going to mainly
do pair functionals.
Pair functionals tends to be
most applicable to metals.
Where I would say the
square root depends,
that effect is strongest,
whereas cluster potentials
or many body
potentials in general
tend to be more favored in
the organic literature--
both organic chemistry
and polymer chemistry.
And so, going to that.
So there's a whole
class of methods
which are called
effective medium theories.
The version of it that
I'm going to discuss
is what's called the embedded
atom method, which is probably
the most popular one.
This was developed by [? Mike ?]
[? Baskis ?] [? and ?]
[? Murray ?] [? Dahl ?] I
think going back to the '80s.
Mid '80s, or
something like that.
And it's probably
now the most popular
of the sort of empirical
energy schemes.
If you look back
at those papers,
those papers have now
over 1,000 citations.
And the idea is
extremely simple.
It's, if you understand
the source of the problem--
that our energy
should not be linear
with coordination-- that's
what you're going to fix.
So in these models,
what you do is
you write the energy per atom
as a function of the number
of bonds around it.
It's just that F
should not be linear.
And so that's why they call it
energy functionals rather than
a pair potential.
The question is, how do you
measure number of bonds?
And if you sort think about
it, if you think yourself
back in the '80s,
how do you want
to measure number of bonds?
You don't really want
to do it discreetly.
Because you could
say, well, maybe I'm
just going to count atoms
within a two-Angstrom radius,
or some radius.
The problem is, as soon as
you measure it discretely,
you're going to have to
deal with discontinuities.
As atoms move in and
out of that radius,
suddenly you've got 14 things
around you instead of 15.
So you would always
have super large forces
because of those discontinuities
around your [? cutoff ?]
interface.
So what you need is a smooth
count of coordination.
And the one they came up with
in the embedded atom method
is literally, you
measure the electron
density being projected on
you from your neighbors.
It's ironic.
I'll show you later the
formal justification
for the embedded atom
method which has a lot more
to do with quantum mechanics.
But that was actually a
justification after the fact.
The original idea
came up with sort of,
you really want to have a
continuous measure of bumbling
around you.
And so the idea is that you're
going to do something like,
I have a central atom.
I have other atoms around me.
How do I measure how much these
contribute to my neighborhood?
Well, these have some electron
density functions around them.
Their atomic electron
density I'm sort of drawing.
And they all project
onto that central atom.
You count up how much
electron density there
and that's somehow a measurement
of your neighborhood.
And you see, that's
going to roughly have
the right behavior.
It's continuous.
As atoms move farther away,
they still contribute,
but they contribute less.
So it is a continuous measure.
And the more
density you project,
either the closer by the
atoms are or the more of them
there are.
OK.
So this is the idea of
the electron density.
You're going to actually
calculate the electron density
on a site as a measurement in
some sense of the coordination
as a sum of electron densities
coming from its neighboring
atoms, J. OK?
What electron densities you
use is kind of less relevant.
In the original embedded atom
and in most embedded atom codes
still, they use essentially
the atomic densities.
So people have calculated
the atomic electron densities
with [INAUDIBLE] methods.
And they're actually tabulated
in these Clementi and Roetti
tables.
And you know, I'm just
sort of showing you
that they're basically
parameterized
by a bunch of Gaussians,
but you can get those.
So you can get those functions.
We skipped through that.
OK.
So remember that if you have--
yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Correct.
Correct.
Well, it's a distance
dependent function.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
Yeah.
So it's sort of what
people in quantum mechanics
think of as sort of non
self-consistent methods.
You literally treat
the electron density
of the crystal as the overlap
of the atomic densities
of the atoms.
The reason that saves you
here is that you're actually
not going to do quantum
mechanics on that density,
and you're just
using that density
as some measure of coordination.
So [INAUDIBLE] I
skipped some slides.
Somehow, I lost
the slide in here.
Sorry about that.
OK.
You know what?
I put it in the wrong place.
Here we go.
So the way you write the energy
in the embedded atom method
is you write it as the
embedding energy, which
is you sum over every atom.
And you're looking for
it's cohesive energy, which
is some function F
of the neighborhood
measurements, which
is the electron
density at the site of i.
And that's your summing
from these functions F
which are the
projected densities
from all the other atoms J.
So this is the nonlinear
part of the energy.
Typically, that is supplemented
with a pair potential.
So the standard
embedded atom method
is a pair potential
which is often
just used for having a
repulsive part and a nonlinear
embedding energy.
So that means we have
to solve three problems,
really-- the one we've solved.
You need to know what the
electron densities are.
Take the Clementi
and Roetti tables.
You need to know what the
embedding function is,
and you need to know what
the pair potential is.
The pair potential,
to be honest,
you can use almost anything.
It's mainly used for the
hardcore repulsion part.
You don't want the atoms
to fly into each other.
Typically, they use some
screened electrostatic form
which is essentially the
product of charge distribution
functions on atoms.
But you know, nothing would
stop you if you really wanted to
from using a Leonard-Jones.
I'll show you in a
second that there
is ambiguity about the division
of energy between the embedding
part and the pair
potential is not unique.
So that means, every time you
change your pair potential,
you'll have to change
your embedding function.
I'll show that in a second.
What do you use for
the embedding function?
There are two ways
that it can be done.
People have written
down analytical forms
with some theoretical
justification
that I'm not going to go into.
There's actually an
excellent review article
on the embedded
atom methods which
we post just for internal
use on the website.
It's a 1993 Materials Science
and Engineering report.
It's a really long paper, but
it's really an excellent paper.
So there are analytical forms.
And here's a few of them given.
And people have come
up with other ones.
More and more now,
what people simply do
is tabulate the
embedding function.
And really what they
do is they tabulate it
so that you exactly reproduce
the equation of state.
What is the equation of state?
The equation of state is
energy versus volume or lattice
parameter.
So say at every level parameter,
you could try to get that
energy with a better method--
say, quantum mechanics--
and then fit your
embedding function
so that you exactly
reproduce that.
And so, often, the embedding
function is tabulated.
But commonly it has this form.
It's decaying, it's sort
of decreasing convex,
decreasing in energy
and convex, and it
needs both those properties.
Well, why does it need to
be decreasing in energy?
So this is the embedding
density and this is the value
of the embedding function.
Of course, as you put
more density on a site,
that comes from more neighbors.
So your cohesive energy
should be going down.
That's why the energy of the
embedding function goes down.
But it needs to be convex
because convexity gives you
sort of the correct behavior.
Convexity really tells you that
adding a bond going from here
to here--
let's say a bond is adding 0.01.
So if we added a bond
here, we'd get this change
in embedding energy.
If we added it here, we'd
only get that change.
So the function has to
be convex in some sense.
Decrease has to be per
unit, and electron density
has to be less for higher
densities than for lower.
And that's the
definition of convex.
The slope of it has to be
increasing of this function.
And you see, that's going
to by construction now get
some of our problems
right because this shape
of the function,
the convexity is
what tells you that
the low coordination
bonds are stronger than the
high coordination bonds.
So you can already
guess from this
that we're going to get
a lot of things right.
I'll show you some
examples in a second.
What's the physical concept
that sort of justifies
the embedded atom method?
There are things
you can do formally
in ab initio theory
showing that in fairly
simple tight binding models.
So these are things
that have the structure
of a proper quantum
mechanical Hamiltonian,
but they are parameterized
forms of a Hamiltonian.
But still, what they
all tend to show
is that the cohesive energy
in highly delocalized systems
to first order goals
like the square root
of the coordination.
So you can get
some justification
for this nonlinear behavior.
A somewhat intuitive concept of
where the bonding energy comes
from is that actually,
if you put an atom
in a metallic solid, where does
it get a cohesive energy from?
For the most part, it
gets its cohesive energy
from the delocalization
of its electrons.
And that's largely a
kinetic energy effect.
Remember that the kinetic
energy in quantum mechanics
is the curvature of
the wave function.
It's d squared phi, dx squared
if you it in one dimension.
So highly curved wave functions
have high kinetic energy.
So if you can
actually delocalize,
your wave function
becomes, in some sense,
much smoother with
much less curvature,
and you have lower
kinetic energy.
So if you believe that a lot
of bonding cohesive energy
and delocalized source
comes from that,
then the measure
of cohesive energy
is essentially how well
you can delocalize it.
So what do you measure
with the embedding density?
If you measure the
electron density coming
from atoms, the reason this
works is that that's probably
a very good measure over
the number of states
you can delocalize over.
Things with higher
electron density
tend to have a higher
number of states--
higher densities of states.
And so you can delocalize
over more states.
And that's the somewhat
intuitive explanation
for why the embedded atom works.
I mean, people have given
somewhat other explanations.
They could say, well,
the electron density
that I see from a
neighboring atom measures
the number of electrons
I can bond with.
But that's not totally true
because if those electrons come
from a filled shell, there's
nothing I can do with them.
So somehow, I tend
to believe more
it's really a measure of
the delocalization you see.
The embedded atom
method is-- yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: Did you
say [INAUDIBLE]??
PROFESSOR: Correct.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yeah.
So in an atom, you actually have
a much higher kinetic energy
because your state is
much more localized.
The embedded atom
method is probably
the most popular one of
all these effective medium
theories.
But you'll see other
ones with other names
that are in spirit very much
the same-- things like the glue
model.
Finnis-Sinclair
potentials, which
slightly predate the
embedded atom method, which
are also non-linear potentials.
So they're really particle
potential pair functionals.
And the equivalent crystal
models Smith and Banerjee.
These are all exactly
in the same spirit.
The brilliance of the
embedded atom method
was essentially that it
was something for nothing.
The computational
cost is essentially
the same as for doing pair
potentials because you
sum things only pairwise.
If you think of what you
need to do an embedded atom
calculation, you have
your pair potential.
That's a pairwise sum.
But your embedding energy
is also a pairwise sum.
Because what you
have to do per atom,
you just have to
sum the electron
density coming from a bunch
of other atoms around you.
So that's a pairwise sum.
And then you just
have to stick it
in F, which is an
extra evaluation.
But embedded atom fundamentally
scales only like N squared.
So that was the
brilliant part of it.
Or in the end, that's
what made it successful.
You could essentially
do much better things
with almost the same
effort as pair potentials.
And that's why it sort
of took off as a method.
And pretty much
anybody in metals
now would use
embedded atom if they
want to get any physics right.
If you want to do demonstration
projects or things
like want to do
billions of atoms,
there can be reasons to go
through much simpler forces
still to evaluate.
But in metals, there's
really no reason
not to use EM over
simple pair potentials.
What do people fit to?
People fit to anything,
like I told you before.
The original EM potentials
were fit to a standard set
of data, which was lattice
parameter, sublimation
energy, elastic constants, and
vacancy formation energies.
Now you'll regularly see papers
in the literature claiming,
I have a better potential
than you for aluminum,
and I have a better potential
than you for nickel.
And some of that is true.
So people are not in the
game of kind of super
optimizing these potentials
for what it's worth.
But the original database was
a set of standard potentials--
largely unknowable metal alloys.
People have spent a lot of
time finding better potentials
on technologically important
alloys like nickel aluminum.
You'll find at least
five potentials
who all claim to be better
than somebody else's potential
on the nickel aluminum system.
So what I want to do now is
just show you some results.
And we're not going to
analyze these in great deal.
But I want to show you so
you get some idea of what
people do with this stuff.
Here's linear thermal expansion
for a bunch of late transition
metals calculated in EM and
calculated in experiment.
And these agree pretty well.
That's maybe not a big surprise
in close packed solids.
The thermal expansion
is largely a measure
of the asymmetry of
your equation of state.
I mean, in complex
materials, that's not true.
But in simple,
close packed metals.
Remember, your equation of
state is slightly asymmetric.
It curves less towards the
high lattice parameters
and the low lattice parameter.
So if you draw
energy versus volume,
it's asymmetric
around the minimum.
And that's why you
have thermal expansion.
Think about it.
It's slightly easier to
fluctuate to the higher volume
than to the lower volume.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Oh, good point.
There is, of course, no
temperature dependence
in the potential itself.
So to do something
like thermal expansion,
you either have to do a dynamic
simulation like molecular
dynamics-- and
we'll come to that--
or you have to
explicitly calculate
the entropic factors that give
you thermal expansion, which
is essentially the
dependence of the phonon
frequencies on volume.
So you can indirectly calculate
the thermal expansion.
But we sort of
haven't got into-- we
will go into micro dynamics.
But of course, in the
potential, there's
no temperature dependence.
Here's activation barriers
for self-diffusion in metals.
These are almost too
good to believe it.
You actually don't get them this
good with quantum mechanics.
So it's almost surprising to
me that they're this good,
if you compare EM to external.
So this is the
activation barrier for--
I forget.
But I thought it was
interstitials self-diffusion,
but I'm not for sure whether
it was interstitial or vacancy
self-diffusion.
You know, here's a bunch
of surface energies.
These are not quite as
good as the experiment.
If you, for example,
look at copper,
here's the experimental number
in ergs per centimeter squared.
And here is the calculation
on different facets.
Because of course,
often experimentally
you measure some average
of different facets.
Unless you do careful
single crystal work,
you have some average.
On the calculations you
have to calculate the energy
on a specific surface.
And that's actually
one of the things
you're going to do in the lab.
So these are a little lower.
And that seems to be a rather
consistent problem that is,
for example, also in platinum.
These are quite a bit
lower than the experiment.
So that may tell you
that either there
are more complicated quantum
mechanical effects going on
that you don't capture with
these simple energy models.
But sometimes, it also means
the experiment is wrong.
I think in this case, platinum
is a fairly easy metal
to deal with clean.
But surface energies
of materials
is sort of notoriously
difficult to get experimental.
Here's a phonon dispersion
curve for copper.
Again, don't worry
about the details.
I just wanted to show you
the kind of things people do.
Calculations are the
lines and the points
are the measurements.
So, reasonably good
at some of these.
High frequencies there seems
to be some problems with.
Melting point.
Again, this would have been
done with molecular dynamics
and then free
energy integration.
And again, for most materials,
these come out remarkably well.
So, look at this.
Except again for the very
late transition metals
like palladium and
platinum, there just
seems to be some
amount of problems.
I can tell you in a second
about the limitations
of these methods.
And they may be related to the
unusual electronic structure
of palladium and platinum.
You know, here's a pair
correlation function
in a liquid.
[? People, ?]
[? we're ?] [? good? ?]
A grain boundary.
This is something
you simply could not
do with a pair
potential in metals
because when you calculate
a grain boundary,
you really are dealing
with different coordinated
environments.
And the painful thing
about a grain boundary
is that you don't know ahead of
time what kind of coordinations
you're going to see.
And you're going to see
multiple coordinations.
See, but people with
potentials always get,
if I know I'm going to
deal with a surface,
I can make a pair
potential that's
pretty good for those
coordinations at the surface.
If I deal with the bulk,
I make a pair potential
that's pretty good with
bulk coordinations.
It's when you work
with grain boundaries
that you kind of end up with
all kinds of coordinations
because the atoms in
the grain boundary,
some are high coordinated,
some are low coordinated,
depending on how the
grains contact each other.
So it's a great method, but
it still has its limitations.
One is that the
bonding is spherical.
You literally sum all
the electron density
coming from around you, and
you really just sum it up.
You don't keep track of
its orientation dependence.
So having one atom there next
to me and one atom on that side
is the same as having both
straight in front of me
because I just sum up the
electron density coming
from them So it's
purely spherical.
That can be fixed.
About in the '90s, [? Mike ?]
[? Baskis ?] developed
what's called a MEAM, and
that just stands for modified
embedded atom method, which
basically has embedding
functions that keep track
of the angular dependence
of the electron
density around you,
essentially by mapping the
problem on to spherical
harmonics.
MEAM is not nearly as
popular as the standard EM
because it adds a level of
complexity to the method.
And it's not totally
clear that you're
making things work because
the physics is better
or you just have more
fitting parameters.
[? Mike ?] [? Baskis ?]
originally developed the MEAM
to work on silicon where
angular dependence clearly seems
to play an important role.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, your force--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Your force is
directional dependent
because you're taking
the derivative of energy
with respect to a vector,
which is some distance.
But--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: But again, the force
will be directional dependent.
Let me show you an example.
Let's say I have a
central atom here
and I got four atoms around it.
The force will be directional
dependent because--
what is the force?
The force is how the
energy of an atom
changes as I move it into
a particular direction.
So the force along
this direction
is the energy change as I move
the atom along this direction
because it is the derivative of
the total energy with respect
to some unit vector
in that direction.
See, if I change
in this direction,
I'm going to
significantly increase
the overlap with that atom.
But if I change it,
say, in this direction,
that's not necessarily
the same derivative
than in this direction.
So the force will be directional
dependent just because
of the crystallography,
but the energy is not.
So what I mean
with that is that--
let's call this some unit
length L, and they're all at L.
If I do this, and
here's my central atom,
and these are all L, that gives
me exactly the same embedding
energy as in the first problem.
Of course, the total
energy will be different
because these guys
interact very closely.
But the bonding energy
of the central atom
is exactly the same.
And that's what I mean
with no angular dependence.
It doesn't in the end see
what orbitals that electron
density comes from.
And when you think about
angular dependence,
in the end, what it is, it
is polarization of orbitals.
Think of sp3 bonding.
What is that really telling you?
If I do an sp3 hybrid
along this direction,
I'm really starting to
polarize the orbitals along--
what is it--
109 degrees in other directions.
So I really need to try to get
my bonds in those directions.
So that's essentially what
angular dependence comes from.
Does that help?
AUDIENCE: [? I ?]
[? think ?] [? so. ?]
PROFESSOR: OK.
You think so.
Well, let me know if it doesn't.
OK.
The other problem
is-- which is more
a technical problem-- is that
the potential is not unique.
And this is something
you just have
to be careful with
if you start messing
around with potential
files yourself.
If you're going to use it as a
black box, you're probably OK.
Let me get you
some notes on that.
The way you can see that
the potential is not unique.
If I have an embedding
function F of rho,
if I define another
embedding function-- we
call it G of rho-- they're
always the electron density.
And I say, that's F of rho
plus some linear term in rho.
You could make the total energy
function exactly the same
with either of the two
embedding functions
just by changing
the pair potential.
And let me show you that.
If I write the energy
as the sum over atoms,
the embedding function on
that atom, plus some air
potential part.
Let me substitute this in.
So I get that this is sum i.
Fi rho plus 1/2 sum
iJ psi iJ, RiJ, plus--
let me-- sum i k sum J
[? not equal ?] i of f
rj where rho i was sum j f.
OK.
Essentially, if you want
to look through the math,
don't worry too much about it.
If you do a linear
transformation on the embedding
function, you see this term
is linear in things coming
from the atoms around it.
It's linear in these
electron density functions.
So anything that's
linear in functions
that I sum from the other atoms
is just like a pair potential
because that's what
a pair potential is.
I sum contributions, OK?
I add up contributions
from the things around me.
So I'm linear in
that contribution.
So any linear part of
the embedding function
just looks like a potential.
This is a pair potential.
This is the sum over
[? 2n. ?] This is i an J,
and I add something up.
So this I could
just add the psi.
So if I add psi to this and
use the embedding function F,
I have exactly the same as
using the embedding function G
and using just
the potential psi.
So the linear part you
can move arbitrarily
between the embedding function
and the pair potential.
So that tells you something
else that's kind of important.
When is a pair potential
alone good in metals?
It's when the embedding
part doesn't change.
If my atoms stay roughly
at the same density,
then all the changes come
from the pair potential part.
OK?
So what would you do--
[INAUDIBLE]---- if you're
having an embedding function
as a function of rho.
If you're working,
say, at this density?
Let's sort of say the
density of the bulk,
and you're studying
bulk problems.
You could take the slope of
this, take the linear term,
make a linear
approximation to that
and add that to
the pair potential,
and now you wouldn't have
to worry about the embedding
function.
So at constant density,
pair potentials
are actually pretty good.
It's when the
density around you--
the electron density
around you changes
which is, in essence, a measure
of the coordination change
that you run into trouble.
And so, people have gone
into that game of making
density dependent potentials.
And so you would have
a different potential
when you're near a surface
than when you're near the bulk.
So my summary on
effective medium theories
which I showed by
embedded atom methods
is, in essence, that there's
no reason not to use them.
If you've decided
you're going to use
an empirical model for metals,
there's really no reason at all
to use pair potentials.
Embedded atom basically does
better at very little cost.
Saying that it
does better doesn't
say that the does everything.
And I remember talking to people
like [? Mike ?] [? Baskis ?]
who invented this.
They're embarrassed for
kind of things people now do
with the embedded atom method.
Like with any successful method,
people push it way too hard
and try to calculate all
kinds of subtle energy effects
that it just never was made for.
And you see people
write papers on,
if I change my
constant by 1,000 here,
I can get this phase correct.
But in the end, it gives
you these gross coordination
effects right, but it does
not give you very subtle
hybridization effects right.
Why, for example, were platinum
and palladium not so good?
Because platinum and palladium
have almost filled or filled
D bands.
And as a function of the
environment around platinum
and palladium, there is very
subtle electron transfer
between the D band
and the S band.
OK?
And when you're just
measuring electron density,
that all looks the
same, but those states
behave very differently.
So there will be always
subtle electronic change
that you simply won't get.
And if your system is really
influenced strongly by those,
you won't get them right.
For example, people try to
get complex crystal structure
differences in metals with EM.
You will just never
get there, period.
Let's say you make an alloy--
palladium ruthenium, whatever--
the crystal structure energy
difference in that
[? material, ?] like in most
metals over the order of 5 to
10 millielectron [? volt. ?] You
cannot get things right on that
scale with these kind of simple
models, so you
shouldn't try too hard.
But on the other hand,
if you're going to study,
say, I don't know, fracture in
a material in a simple element
like one of these big
movies I showed you,
that's to a large extent
a topological event.
You will get a lot of
essential pieces of that right.
Because what is that?
That's a coordination
change event, largely.
You will get a lot of that right
by doing EM over potentials.
This is a great
website I only added
that this year to
the lecture I found.
There's a group in
Japan that called
themselves the [? EAMers. ?]
They even have a blog now.
And so there's a lot of
cool stuff you can download.
They have potential files.
You can get EM code
from the Sandia site.
It's a little hard to
get to, because Sandia
being a national
lab, they're totally
paranoid about
downloading anything.
But there are sources where
you can get the EM code.
It is technically
freely available.
It's just not necessarily
trivial to get to it.
So we talked about
pair functionals,
which was this direction.
So the other
direction is obviously
to go to cluster potentials.
Well, you know, I
don't like my expansion
in just two-body terms.
I'll start adding
three-body terms.
It's the obvious extension.
And if you don't like that,
you can go to four-body terms.
That's definitely done.
And for reasons I'll go into
in the next lecture on Tuesday,
it's extremely
popular in the world
of organics, where it's actually
really, really powerful.
And we'll go into
why that is the case.
But a typical material
in condensed matter
where obviously this
was done was silicon.
Silicon is a low coordinated
solid-- only fourfold
coordinated in the
diamond cubic structure.
It's extremely hard to get
that with a pair potential
because again, your systems
always try to form FCC or HGP,
essentially.
So what you can do is build
a three-body potential
that favors these 190-degree
tetrahedral angles.
And as soon as you do
that, if you actually
make that force
strong enough, you
can do almost nothing else
than form diamond cubic.
Because diamond
cubic is basically
the way to pack atoms and put
them under all these 109--
what is it-- .4 or
something degree angles.
So if you make a strong
enough three-body force,
you will by definition end up
in the diamond cubic structure.
If you work with
three coordinates,
you can also transform
that and instead
work with two
distances and an angle.
So if I have three atoms,
the coordinates of them,
I can also always say that to
have the relation between them,
I just need to have these two
distances and this angle that
fully defines the
three-body problem.
And that's usually
how it's done.
People have pair potentials
that take care of the distance
dependence of that.
And then they have
an angular potential
which takes care of the
angle between these.
And often, the prefactor
of the angular potential
will have some
distance depends in it.
Because of course,
maybe you want
to enforce this
190-degree angle when
your two other atoms are close.
But when they're very far,
you don't really care anymore.
What's the possible choices
for angular potentials?
The simplest one is simply a
quadratic-- a harmonic function
in the angle.
If you want to impose
an angle theta naught,
you make a potential
that's literally
a quadratic around theta naught.
So, extremely
simple to evaluate.
So that function's
actually often used.
You can also use--
the disadvantage of this one
is that it's not periodic.
Angle measurements
should be periodic.
So you can kind of get
into trouble with this
if you go too far
from equilibrium.
So another thing you can use
is a cosine function which
has the proper periodicity.
If you take--
I don't know--
109 degrees or whatever
angle you want, or you
take its complement--
360 minus that-- you
should get the same answer.
And so, cosine functions
will do that right.
And this one, cosine
theta plus 1/3, this part
is minimal when theta is
109 with tetrahedral angle.
[CLEARS THROAT] Excuse me.
Losing my voice.
So it works working with
three-body potentials.
It's, of course, more work.
It's not [? order ?] N cubed.
Because, for every
atom, you now have
to look at distance and
angles with pairs of atoms.
OK so it becomes an N cubed
operation, so it's more work.
And calculating the forces as
the derivatives of the energy
is also quite a bit more work.
The most famous three-body
potential is probably
the Stillinger Webber potential
which, as you can see,
has this cosine
theta form for the--
this is the angular part.
This is the distance
dependence of the angular part.
So how much should you penalize
angular deviations [INAUDIBLE]..
And then this is
the two-body part.
Just sort of a more
[? slight ?] potential.
Originally, Stillinger
Webber, when they actually
wrote down the function,
they didn't even
fit it very carefully.
I mean, it was a great form,
but they just kind of did
a rough fit.
And so, the original
Stillinger Webber parameters
and the ones people now
use sometimes more recently
are not the same anymore.
The potential has the same form.
But some people have done
recently better fits.
So when somebody says that
Stillinger Webber potential,
there are variations of
it for the constants.
So what do you get
right with a [? sale ?]
something like a Stillinger
Webber potential?
Well, you can kind of
guess why people did this.
Because silicon is
so important, they
wanted to be able to
model silicon right.
So it's important to understand
which pieces you get right.
One of the critical issues
was surface reconstruction.
If you take silicon 111--
sorry, 100.
If you truncate it,
it actually undergoes
a 2 times 1 reconstruction.
What essentially happens if
you take this top layer atoms,
they're only bonded to
two atoms below them,
and so they dimerize
on the surface.
So basically,
these move together
in sort of double rows.
I need a better color.
And then these
will move together.
And so they double the
periodicity in one direction.
And so you have these
dimers that form.
And because of that,
the surface atom
is bonded to three other atoms--
two below it, one all
the way in the surface.
And so they're better bonded.
And that's the 2 by
1 reconstruction.
The 2 by 1 reconstruction you
get right with the Stillinger
Webber potential.
You'd actually get it
right with almost anything.
It's essentially a
topological reconstruction.
You know, atoms like to have
more atoms around them to bond,
period.
And so that's what drives
a 2 by 1 reconstruction.
At the top layer, atoms now are
at least threefold coordinated
and they're actually almost
fourfold coordinated instead
of twofold coordinated at just
an unreconstructed terminated
surface.
But here's the reconstruction
on the 111 surface.
The reconstruction on the
111 surface is 7 by 7.
So it forms a much larger
unit cell on the surface.
And that is not reproduced
by the Stillinger Webber
potential.
So clearly, that's a
more subtle effect.
Silicon, being such
an important material,
has a multitude of potentials.
Everybody sort of has
made one and claims
theirs is better than yours.
And I just show this
graph not for the details,
but to show you that
this isn't even a tenth
of the potentials
made for silicon,
but some of the famous ones.
SW-- Stillinger Webber--
[? bismuth, ?] [? Harman, ?]
and the Tersoff potentials,
which are quite famous for
silicon, are not even on here.
But if you see, this
is the angular part
of these potentials.
It's very different.
They all give the same answer,
unlike static properties
like the elastic properties of
silicon, the cohesive energy,
the lattice parameter.
But it's sort of divided
differently between pair parts
and angular parts.
This one clearly
wouldn't give you
the same stiffness
of bond bending
around the typical
dihedral angle.
And that shows up.
There's what I thought
was a really nice paper.
Oh, and I'm sorry, I-- oh, no.
The reference [? isn't ?] here.
This is the [? Norman ?]
[? and ?] [? paper ?] from
Physical Review B. They did
what I thought was brilliant.
They did exactly
the same simulation
with three different potentials.
Left is the Stillinger
Webber potential,
and then middle column is
Tersoff [? 2. ?] This is
the Tersoff potential, and then
Tersoff [? 3. ?] So this is
exactly the same Monte Carlo
simulation with the three
potentials.
And this is the [? 001 ?] or
[? 100 ?] surface of silicon.
So remember, that's the one
I showed you that dimerizes.
And so the top line
is at low temperature.
Tersoff [? 3 ?]
doesn't dimerize.
Tersoff 2 does sort of dimerize.
And so does Stillinger
Webber, but they
look slightly different.
But these are in
reasonable agreement.
If you go higher in temperature,
then Tersoff [? 3 ?] dimerizes.
So does the Stillinger Webber.
But Tersoff [? 2 ?] starts
kind of looking quite different
already.
So these are
potentials that, if you
looked at how they
reproduce static properties,
they all do extremely well.
But it's extremely hard to
fit to dynamical properties
because you don't have that
as quantitative information
very often.
Like, first of
all, we don't know
what the right answer is here.
But even if we did, let's say,
somebody does brilliant STM
and we know the right answer,
it's very hard to feed
that back into a potential.
And so the reason
I'm telling you
this is not to dissuade
you from using [INAUDIBLE]
when you need them.
It's just to make
sure you're cautious.
There's a big reason that
people do ab initio calculations
these days.
It's not because they
necessarily like it,
but it's because
the results tend
to be more reliable, or
at least predictable.
The errors are more
predictable, let's put it
that way, which is a
useful thing to have.
Having error is one thing.
Having unpredictable
error is a lot worse.
But still, there will always
be problems where they're just
too complex, or you want
to do them fast where you
want to use pair potentials.
Just don't always believe
everything you see.
Try to fit as close
to where you're
going to explore the
physics that's essentially
[? meaning. ?]
OK, here's a bunch
of references.
I'll actually put these
on the Stellar website.
We'll finish the empirical
potential lecture.
We'll go into organics
and a little bit
of polymers on Tuesday.
And then Professor
[? Marzari ?] will
start giving you introduction
to basic quantum mechanics.
And then we'll start sort
of ab initio energy methods,
and Professor
[? Marzari ?] will do that.
So I'll be still
lecturing on Tuesday.
So have a good weekend, and
I'll see you on Tuesday.